I cannot believe who we have here today
Tony Robbins is coming on the podcast
Tony Robbins is the number one life
coach performance coach in the world
he's the highest paying public speaker
of all time this guy's built a business
Empire that does 7 billion a year in
Revenue um incredible entrepreneur and
Coach I mean this guy's customers his
clients the guys who pay him to coach
them are like you know top athletes uh
you know Serena Williams and Tom Brady
and Conor McGregor you know um
politicians Nelson Mandela Bill Clinton
uh the top Traders and investors in the
world Ray doio Paul tutor Jones they pay
him because they know that Tony is can
help be their Edge right uh he can help
them level up so if he can help them
level up I think we can learn a lot from
him I'm going to ask about three
specific things the first is I actually
went to a Tony Robbins event eight years
ago this is my notebook from that event
uh I still have it eight years ago eight
years later and the reason why is
because I hate to be that guy who's like
I went to a self-help semon art it
changed my life but it did uh I really
came out a different guy I came out a
happier guy I ended up you know at the
time I you know this podcast called my
first million I didn't have my first
million then and I came up with a plan I
came up with a strategy and I stuck to
it after that event I made I did it
because he I made three specific shifts
and so I know most of you will never go
to one of his events you'll never go to
the seminar it's a four-day thing it's
kind of weird it's not as cool as just
going to Coachella or whatever but I
want to ask Tony about those specific
three shifts so that you can hear from
him exactly what I heard in that event
that changed my life that's what we're
going to do on this podcast today those
same exact things that Chang my life I'm
going to have him explain on the podt
today it's kind of like a live coaching
session we're just people pay this guy a
million bucks to do this and we're going
to get it for free uh also at the end of
this uh Tony doesn't know this but I'm
going to actually give away just under
$100,000 worth of tickets to his seminar
so for people who are listening to this
there'll be directions at the end of how
you can actually get a free ticket to go
to one of his things if you so choose so
that money is not your limitation so the
least I could do this guys helped me out
so much in my life I would love to pay
it forward to the next person and uh and
send them to the seminar um lastly we
talk about his his new book which he's
been interviewing all these billionaires
right the they this Championship mindset
right he works with the top 1% of the 1%
and I want to know what's different what
are they doing differently he tells a
story about an investor who bought 40
million nickels like literally like the
coin the Nickels uh why they did that
and why that was such a good idea um I
wanted to hear some of these stories
from him hanging out with these
billionaire investors um because he
doesn't talk about that a lot and I I'm
I nerd out about that kind of thing so
enjoy this episode with Tony Robbins
this is a real uh cool moment for me
with this podcast to be able to do this
I thank Tony for coming on and I hope
you enjoy
[Music]
it pull this one out today uh to just do
a little refresher where'd you go when
didd you go I went to New Jersey it's
actually a funny story I had heard oh
Tony Robins is Mot motivational speaker
and I kind of was like oh do I do I need
motivation I don't need motivation I
don't either but there was something
inside me that because when you when I
had watched your videos I thought well
it's not just that I mean he's a he's an
entrepreneur he's doing his company's
doing billions in Revenue he's clearly a
leader and when I went to this event I
knew that it wasn't just like it wasn't
just some generic self-help BS and I go
and a couple things stood out right away
I just want to tell you about this my
experience at your event so I go and the
very first thing that happens is I plan
to just sit back I'm here to learn okay
I'm not going to jump I'm not going to
do all that dancing jumping around stuff
this is my mentality 15 minutes later
that's out the window I'm into it I'm
having a great time uh the second thing
is I notice I see these celebrities up
front these are some of the most
successful people I know all right uh I
I hear this scream that almost sounds
familiar I look over and it's Jedd
Butler the guy from 300 like the Spartan
I'm like all right if he's into this I I
think I could be into this uh you know
like you have this thing like give your
neighbor a high five I turned it's
Vanessa hudgin I'm like giving her a hug
I had this amazing experience and when I
was there it was one guy who turned and
looked at me and he said first time huh
because you just see this grin on my
face and I was like yeah this is not
your first time and he goes no I've been
to five of these and honestly I was like
a little discouraged I was like you got
to come to this thing five times like I
don't know is that how this works and I
go why' you come five times he goes
because when Michael Jordan's in his
prime and he comes to your town you go
watch him play yeah and I thought that
was one of the best compliments I said
Michael Jordan he said yeah he's this is
the Michael Jordan he's like he does
many things but he's the Michael Jordan
of public speaking and after that I
started looking at what you were doing
differently you work with billionaires
and presidents and athletes and all this
stuff but every superhero has a origin
story right like Spider-Man got bit by
The Spider and that's you know that's
where he got his powers from I think
your origin story is amazing and not not
a lot of people know the full story can
you take me back you're 17 years old I
think you're a part-time janitor and
you'd never been to a seminar in your
life how did you what was your spider
bite how did you stumble into this
that's interesting question I was
already interested in personal
development because I had a kind of a
rough background I have four different
fathers we had no money for food I had
to work two jobs work as a janitor and
my mom had a friend and dad had a friend
that had been my my dad my dad's
description was he used to be such a
loser and now he's really successful and
so he called and said listen I hear your
son's gotten big I was I I was 51 in
high school and I I was 6'2 by my senior
year I grew 10 inches in a year I tell
people the difference is personal growth
by the
way but the bottom line is he said you
know I I got to move some furniture and
things I heard he's big you know could
he come work for the weekend for some
extra money so I did I worked really
hard and the guy really was impressed by
their work e think so he said I'm gonna
take you to lunch we go to this lunch
and you know and he's saying you know I
really think you go place you got a lot
of drive and I said well I'd like to ask
you some questions and he said okay and
I said my dad used to say he used to be
such a loser and now you're so
successful how'd you do that you know
only a kid can say this right I wasn't
trying to be cute I just literally
repeated it you go said what then he's
like well it's kind of true and he said
well I went to this seminar and I said
what is this seminar I've never heard of
such thing he said well a man who has
really become accomplished takes 20
years of his life and teaches you in
three and a half hours the best of what
you need to know to make your life work
I said wow that sounds really
interesting I said could you get me in
and he said yeah and there was no
followup so I said well well will you
and he said no I said why not he said
well because if you don't pay for it you
won't value it and at the time I was
working as janer making 40 bucks a week
so I said uh how how much is it he said
$35 it'd be like $250 and and you
today's dollars to give you an idea but
it was a week's pay is all I knew and I
was like are you kidding me for three
hours I said no one of the guy's Rich he
goes no that's not it he said he really
has these tools but he said if you think
it's too much then you go learn on your
own experience and take 10 or 20 or 30
years and maybe never learn it at all
and so long story short I made what I
thought was the biggest decision of my
life to take a week's pay and I went and
heard Jim Ron speak and I was deeply
moved I left there going okay I'm going
to become president United States I'm
going to start with a plan of running
for junior in high school I'm going to
run for student body president I'm going
to be a state I was just looking to have
the most impact but what it led to was
me just really digging in and learning
everything I could about human
development and then very quickly
because I was studying everything I get
my hands on I came across neural
linguistic programming NLP which at the
time was a break through new technology
of how to use language to change human
emotion and behavior and I talk my way
into this you know six-month class I was
the only non- therapist in the class and
um and after the first weekend I was
just out using it I stop I'd go to
literally this the program I went to was
at the airport holid in in LAX and I'd
go to the Denny's that was right next
door afterwards and look for people to
help you it's like here say I'm gonna
change your life but and then gradually
I started modeling and I started
figuring other skills and I started
challenging traditional psychologists
and psychiatrists saying give me your
worst patient I'll handle them in an
hour and I took people with lifetime
phobias you know been in therapy seven
years and turned around in an hour and
that built my reputation and so then I
started working with athletes and then I
started work with Mother Teresa Nelson
Mandela and gorbachov and you know
President Clinton and it just grew and
grew and then along the way I used some
the same skills called modeling finding
out what is makes the difference in
performance around businesses and I
started building companies so today you
know now I have 111 companies we do over
S7 billion dollars in business across
radically different Industries and uh
but this is my mission this what I do on
a daily basis here my education company
is what I value most but that's kind of
the journey and I've had lots of ups and
downs along the way obviously it wasn't
like a straight up experience by any
stretch it's not a straight line but
I've learned hell of a lot I've been
surrounded by a lot of great people
along the way all right everyone a quick
break to tell you about HubSpot and this
one's easy because I'm going to show you
an example of how I'm doing this at my
company when I say I I mean not my team
I mean I'm the one who actually made
this so I've got this company called
Hampton you can check it out join
hampton.com it's a community for
Founders and one of the ways that we've
grown is we've created these surveys but
we'll ask our members certain questions
that a lot of people a lot of times
people are afraid to ask so things like
what their net worth is how their assets
are allocated all these like interesting
questions and then we'll put it in a
survey and I went and made a landing
page so you can check it out at join
hampton.com wealth you can actually see
the landing page that I made and the
hard part with this is with Hampton we
are appealing to a sort of a a higher
customer sort of like like a Louis
Vuitton or Ferrari so I needed the
landing page to look a very particular
way HubSpot has templates that's what we
use we just change the colors a little
bit to match our brand very easy they
have this drag and drop version of their
Landing Page Builder and it's super
simple I'm not Technical and I'm the one
who actually made it and once it's made
I then shared it on social media and we
had thousands of people see it and
thousands of people who gave us their
information and I can then see over the
next handful of weeks this is how much
revenue came in from this wealth survey
that I did this is where the revenue
came from so it came from Twitter it
came from LinkedIn whatever it came from
I can actually go and look at it and I
can say oh well that worked that didn't
work do more of that do less of that and
if you're interested in making landing
pages like this I highly suggest it look
I'm actually doing it but you can check
it out go to the link in the description
of YouTube and get started all right now
back to MFM I don't know if you've seen
this have you seen this little clip of
Jim Rome talking about you no I have not
let's play this all right can you play
that clip Tony Robbins sat in my seminar
when he was
17 17 he was on the outs with his
parents and he was sleeping in his car
and someone got him to come to my
seminar age 17 so you don't you never
know who's in the
audience and he worked for me for three
and a half years promoting my seminars
back then called adventures and
achievement three and a half years
finally ran one of my offices at age 20
in Los Angeles Tony Robbins now he's a
big-time Superstar bigger superstar than
I am around the world unbelievable and
he mastered all the stuff you know I
didn't teach him to firew walk and all
all that stuff
but that's Tony style you know he can
get by with that I couldn't do that I
did say to him one time Tony you got to
do water instead of fire they'll come
from all over the
world and knowing Tony guess what he'll
probably try
it it kid's unbelievable he's
unbelievable so what's it like I mean
hearing your Mentor you know somebody
who became a friend but but start off as
a you were the student he was a teacher
in a way how does it feel hearing that
no he was a teacher for sure he taught
me some of the most important things I
think the most important thing he taught
me um was when I was you know I had all
these different fathers and we were
always broke and so he said change your
mindset change it from can I earn twice
as much in the same amount of time 10
times as much 50 times a 100 times a
thousand times yes if you become more
valuable so you have to work harder on
yourself than you do on your job and he
said you've got to understand whatever
you do do add more value than anybody
else in the marketplace of what you do
and that really it it it sung to me
because I always try to overd deliver in
anything I did even at that stage of my
life and um that's been the basis of
every company that I built across all
these different Industries I there's no
way i' be I am without that piece so I'm
indebted to Jim as my first Mentor one
of the questions I wanted to ask you is
you can't ask Steph Curry how do you
make a jump shot it's too complicated
right I can't ask you how do you be a
good public speaker but I can ask you
how did you get good cuz my sense is yes
you had some natural gifts however I
want to bet and you tell me if I'm right
or wrong that from the ages of kind of
like 17 when you went to that first
seminar to maybe 25 26 27 I would bet
that you probably got more reps in than
anybody else in your field is that I I
could be wrong tell me if I'm wrong I
went to work for Jim Ron the personal
development speaker so you would go out
and make two talks maybe three talks in
a month where you would go to a real
estate office or a stock brokerage or
someplace where you would do a talk and
show them by improving themselves they
could also improve their income that's
usually what they were interested in and
so what I did different was I went out
and said I remember the guy that was
number one in the in the whole company
there were about a thousand employees in
that company and I went up to him the
first day because he was such a jerk to
people I mean it's like total jerk and
so I you know I've always been a kind of
protective of the little guy I was a
little guy I was 5-1 I was protective
back then right when I was in high
school so I went up to him and I just
said you know what I said you're an
absolute idiot and I you better remember
my name I said because it'll only be a
few months before I'll dwarf you and I
said I'll tell you why you're lazy you
do three talks a month I'm going to do
three talks a day so it doesn't matter
if I'm as good as you are I'm going to
destroy you right and I did I booked
myself uh to every kind of group you can
imagine but yes you know if you know uh
I I'm fortunate enough to own a piece of
the Golden State Warriors and I've
coached the team I I haven't been there
this year again I've been had a chance
but they need it but Steph is a perfect
example of what you're describing
because people don't know the greatest
three point shooter in the league when
he was you know in high school he was
really good the dad trained him
continuously his dad was an NBA player
but his dad at one point he's the best
player in the league told him we got to
change your jump shots we get a jump
shots we got to change it you start it
too low you'll never make it the NBA and
so he made him have to do this new form
of jump shot and he became terrible
because you're terrible when you try to
do something new but he wouldn't let him
play competitively until he could shoot
well in this way and then now he still
does it he shoots you know 500 shots a
day to give you an idea 3500 shots a
week think about it 14,000 shots a month
168,000 shots a year these are practice
shots so he's been in the NBA 15 years
he's done
2.52 million shots in practice in his
entire career's only taken 15,000 shots
and he's made 3,003 pointers and he's
the greatest in history less than one
tenth of 1% of his shots have actually
shown up in a game so I always tell
people you're rewarded in public for
what you practice in private I think
that's an amazing strategy is that is
that your method to kind of learning in
general how do you think about that I
think of learning at two levels I think
of learning as immersion the reason I do
12 hours a day for three or four days in
a row most people wouldn't sit for a
three-hour movie someone spent 300
million to make I can do it because I
know how to engage people in all their
senses in other words how much is a long
time some people say 10 minutes some
people say 10 years right but really a
long time is when you're not enjoying
yourself you know a minute can feel like
eternity if you're in pain but if you're
enjoying yourself time flies and so my
whole mindset was I got to immerse
people because that's how we learn if
you're learn a language and you learn a
little bit of your time in high school
and college most people don't speak the
language but if I took you to Italy and
dropped you in Rome and said I'll pick
you up in 90 days with no teacher you're
GNA be speaking Italian by the time I
pick you up because of the immersion so
I like to immerse myself but immerse
myself with someone who is the best in
the world at something someone who's
already done it not somebody who's
teaching me intellectually like going to
a university with somebody understands
it but has never done it I wanted to
model the very best in the world so I I
would go interview with I'd go to work
for people in the very early days as a
janitor so I could get around them so I
could learn how they think and what they
do gradually I got to the point where I
had these skills and so I could help
people and so I'd help them but then I'd
also learn from them everybody I've ever
coached who calls me a coach I'm no
dummy I learned from them so some of my
dearest friends in the world when people
started us coaching like Mark Betty off
of Salesforce he came to my seminar I
think four times in a row and he as big
as I am he stands out and on the fourth
one he came up introduced himself and
said you know I'm Mark Benny off and
you've convinced me to leave Oracle I'm
going to start my own company that's
called salesforce.com and want you come
on the journey with me and I'll never
forget he said to me he said we're going
to do a we're going to change business
around the world and I promise you we'll
do a hundred million doar in business
and now he's doing 35 billion right it's
he worth so it's like and he's done that
in 16 years you know the growth has been
unbelievable so Mark says I'm his coach
yeah I've learned as much from Mark or
more than he's learned from me same
thing with Peter goober you know Peter
and I are Partners the Golden State
Warriors the LA Dodgers you know we both
uh invested and started with the LFC
football club he's got 52 Academy Award
nominations he's you know he's one of
the most brilliant IM and beings that I
know so I learned from him so all the
people that I've coached over the years
I've learned from and I've tried to do
it through immersion the more you can
imers yourself where you're thinking
breathing doing something 18 20 hours a
day the faster you're going to learn so
that's how I go about it what's
something you learned from Peter because
he's a fascinating guy that I think most
people don't you know of his work but
you don't know him necessarily he's not
super out there publicly talking all the
time and trying to share knowledge do
you have any good Peter grber stories or
uh or Lessons Learned you've had now
that you partner with him on some things
how he thinks I say one of the most
valuable principles I learned from him
him and a and a friend of his when we
became friends at one stage you know he
said change my life I want to do some do
some more things with you and he had a
small group of men about 8 to 10 that
had been getting together twice a year
sometimes three times a year they go on
these amazing trips and they just
brainstorm but everybody there was the
master of their Universe right so it' be
like Pat Riley you know was at the time
you know the winningest coach in NBA
basketball uh you'd have the richest man
in Canada like this amazing who and so
he invited me to come on this trip with
him and he said look we've never brought
anybody in before you're 18 years
younger than just about everybody here
but you have so much to out I convince
the guys let you come on the trip and if
they like you maybe you come part of the
group and come on a regular basis now
this is I'm just starting my businesses
I'm early on in my career of 30 31 years
old and I'm in a place where he wants me
to go off on this 12 day trip well I
couldn't leave my business for 12 days
in those days I was a business operator
I wasn't an owner like I am today so I
had to go on the trip and on the trip
though it was such a push I didn't want
to miss it I did it I was so stressed
out because I felt like didn't belong
there so uh he didn't had this
conversation with me about what I want
to do with my life and then he said well
let me tell you the most important
principle to get you there he said
proximity Is Power and he and Peter B
started nodding and saying this is what
makes everything work and I said what do
you mean proximity Is Power what do you
mean by that he said to me at the time
you know how many investment bankers do
you know I said no I don't know maybe a
dozen he goes how do you spend time with
I said not he goes that's a huge mistake
you must go spend time with them because
as you spend time they will think of you
and they will come up with deals that
will help you generate the economics you
want to generate if you want to run for
office or do something of that nature
and I said okay and so I started doing
it I felt really uncomfortable and then
I saw him again and he really gave me
stuff and so then I did it deliberately
ongoingly and for a year and a half I'd
go meet people I I'm I'm not a networker
per se um because I felt like I I don't
know I'm not asking for something and I
don't know what I can do for them I try
to always be a giver and but nothing
came out of I mean some good friendships
and so for no business came out of and
one day I got a phone call that led to a
$50 million deal for me and then another
day about a year later converted that
into making in one single day $400
million taking a company public so I
always tell people if you think about
important principles one of the most
important ones I learned from Peter and
his friends was you've got to get in the
environment where the best people in the
world are on a regular basis and add
value and then things will start to
happen nothing accelerates more than
that other than your own skills and
development one of the things I got from
being in proximity with you at your
events immersion going there for four
days and and and really soaking it all
in was would you came on stage there was
an energy shift every time and you you
mentioned Mark Ben off I know You'
talked at the Salesforce conference and
I watched the video and he he said
something great he goes the next guy
who's coming out here he doesn't I mean
Salesforce is like you know a bunch of
sales reps in the audience as it's a
white collar crew they're all sitting
down they've been at a thing all day he
says he doesn't come out to a cold room
and he goes so if you if Toon's G to
come out here we better are warm up
right now and immediately everybody
raised their standard of how they were
going to show up for you and you came
out and you had a certain energy with
you I stole that and I started using
that I said I don't come out to cold
rooms anymore I raised my own standard
in that way that's great but I it it's
not just in the work context because um
even though I went to your event because
I wanted to be more successful and more
ambitious whatever and I had these goals
I wanted to have you know $10 million by
the time I was 30 and then you know
today it's like our companies this year
will do like $50 million in Revenue
raises it's it's it's continued to grow
but the thing I took away the most
wasn't any of the work stuff it was how
you show up at home you had this thing
that I want you to talk about called the
honey I'm home energy I've been doing
this now for like eight straight years
since I I went to your event people
don't know this explain what coming home
with the Honey about that yeah that's uh
it's just really simple it's just I
remember my father used to come home my
fora especially when the door closed
there was this pause and we waited to
see what kind of state he was going to
be in and you could tell if he was in an
unhappy State you want to kind of avoid
the environment or if he'd say monkey
gurus you used say this fre monkey gurus
made no sense but he had so much
enthusiasm and excitement in his voice
that we knew it was a good day so I
thought when I come home I want to make
a difference so my wife and I have this
little thing that we do is I come home
honey I'm home and then we look for each
other and we run towards each other just
hug each other and kiss but it's a it's
a beautiful ritual that we've you know
we've been together 24 years and we
still have this aliveness and passion
for each other because we still put
ourselves in those high energy states
it's easy because of being worn down by
work or environments or kids or some of
your family's ill or financial pressure
in your business let's say to let your
state drop and then when you're around
your partner that's what they experience
all the time and then their State's low
and then you're both filtering life
through that so I think it's really
important just like if you're going to
get up and be a perform in a peak state
if you're going to P Peak results you
got to be in a peak State you got to
train yourself to do it at home and then
after a while it's not phony it's just
like if you see an athlete they have
muscles you know why do the muscle
because they work out regularly well
when you push yourself into a great
state regularly it becomes your standard
and it becomes how you feel all the time
you kind of wire yourself with that it's
not to say you don't have down times or
frustrating times or sad times or
whatever have all those things but
they're not the majority of the time and
if they happen you can snap out of it
fast because you know how to and I think
that's a huge part of what I try to
teach people is that you don't have to
accept how you feel and people all times
say well I don't feel like it well if if
I waited till I felt like it I wouldn't
do 90 % of stuff I've done in my life
I've learned how to make myself feel
like it um because if you don't do that
you're you're not going to accomplish or
achieve or enjoy your life at the level
that you deserve and probably desire
right you said something about the 90
seconds of suffering can you explain
this concept because I stole this I
stole this like it's Oceans 11 and I
came into I stole this framework from
you and I have been using it since then
I'm glad you stole it that's that's a
worthy thing is still
stealing life is too short to suffer I
I'm not going to suffer I know how to
change my state but I want to create a
rule that within 90 seconds if I start
to suffer I'm going to snap out of it
now don't get me wrong it doesn't mean
you don't get angry or frustrated or
pissed off or worried or any of those
things I can have all those feelings but
if you train yourself to snap out of it
90 seconds and by the way in the
beginning no problem 90 seconds and easy
things but then life gives you some big
tests right you get something feels more
like 90 days than 90 seconds but you get
it's like any skill like like shooting
the basket you do it again and again and
again you get better better and better
and it's changed my life because no
matter what's going on I can still find
the beauty in that and in a beautiful
State of Mind you'll come up with the
answers much quicker than a pissed off
state or a fearful state or a lousy
State plus it gives a gift to everybody
else who wants to be around somebody
who's in a crappy state right think
about it like this you know if you have
a if you have cable or you have
satellite and you turn the channel
there's certain channels where it's all
comedy other ones all drama other ones
it's all horror right other ones it's
you know romance well the Channel
Changers your body because if you look
at the greatest athletes in the world
Tom Brady you know locally here in
Florida you know we have a group that's
won the Stanley Cup over and over gun
the Tampa Bay Lightning and they're
famous for coming from behind and
winning so the the same group did test
on them before they ever worked with me
and they discovered there's a
biochemistry of what they call
Championship biochemistry it's where
these people like Tom Brady's down by 10
points and it's the fourth quarter of
the Super Bowl and he comes back the way
I mean how he has this huge huge surge
of testosterone which gives you total
focus and drive it also makes you
remember everything it's like if I ask
you where you at 911 everybody remembers
the moment actually where you're 811 no
one knows where they were right because
you don't have that surge of
testosterone the energy but usually
testosterone is matched by cortisol
which is a stress hormone but in this
case their cortisol drops through the
floor so all they get is pure focus and
drive now it doesn't guarantee you're
going to succeed but increases your
chances about 10 fold
every time I get on stage I develop that
biochemistry love it and uh I have so
many more questions but I also I feel
like your PR team I feel like there's a
red dot that's going to come on me if I
don't talk about your book so I want to
ask you a question about this so I read
the advanced copy of your book so the
Holy Grail of investing it's the third
of these kind of like money related
books that you've been doing which has
been fun because I like the business
side that's obviously where I kind of
nerd out yeah tell the story about the
guy you you know who I think he's a
billionaire who who bought millions of
nickels and why this guy bought millions
of nickels I think this was so fun and
uh you got to tell that story let me let
me give people a little background so
I've written three books on finance I I
started back in 201 13 because after the
2008 Dropout I've been working with Paul
tutor Jones one of the top 10 financial
traders in the history of the world I've
coached him for 24 years he hasn't lost
money during that time so I've learned a
lot um but when I saw that the way we
dealt with 2008 was we instead of
punishing the people that almost
destroyed the system we gave them more
of our money it just blew my mind and so
I I thought I can't change everything
but I have access so I decided to write
a book where I interview 50 of the
smartest Financial investors in the
world the most successful all self-made
billionaires nobody from Lucky sperm
Club they didn't inherit it they created
it you know Ray do Carl icon Warren
Buffett Paul Tor Jones all of them so I
was interviewing a gentleman that took
$30 million and turned it into $2
billion in 20082 2009 the worst economic
time and um and I I asked him I said
how' you do this and he went
asymmetrical RIS reward I've heard that
from every great investor I said okay I
understand what that means but how' you
do it how he did it was he saw the in
the mortgages and everybody thought
these mortgages were going to hold up
and it real estate was going to grow
forever and he knew that wasn't true and
he bet against it with unique tools so
he literally he could be wrong 13 times
to still make money so that's how he
turned that money around and made the
greatest return in just about any period
of time so I asked him I said his name
is Kyle bass I said Kyle I said how
would you explain this to like someone
who's unsophisticated and how would you
explain it to your kids he goes Tony I
can't believe you said that I just
recently asked myself the same question
so I want my kids to understand this
principle because that's what'll make
him wealthy and he said so I fought how
can I do this he said for six months I
kept asking the question where can I
find an investment that is so
asymmetrical there's no downside and
there's huge upside immediately now most
people say you're an idiot to even ask
that question there's no such investment
right no risk no reward and he goes no
he goes smart people ask questions
nobody else ask I kept asking and I
finally came up the answer Nicholls I
said Nichols goes yes he goes here's how
it works nickles to make a nickel cost
11 cents that's how screwed up our
government is and he said and he said so
years ago pennies used to have copper
that's almost no coppernick he goes
those pennies are worth two cents he
said the reason is because the copper
Valu is there but also now they're so
unique right he said so I thought
Nicholls don't never be worth less than
5 cents I want to buy as many nickels as
I can because he said the Meltdown value
alone would give me 30% return on day
one 30% I like investment where you
can't lose money and you're guaranteed
at least 30% I said yeah but I've seen
the rules you can't melt money anymore
he goes yes I know that's what they say
he said but I don't even have to melt it
Tony the same thing happened to pennies
is will happen to nickels he said they
can't do 11 Cent 5cent nickels forever
once it changes the value of these
original nickels is going to be great so
he went to the fed and asked how many
nickels he could buy and I figet the
number was millions of nickels it was
truckloads of nickels he has kids unload
them and put them in he said if I could
push a button and convert my entire
assets to nickels I do it tomorrow I
can't ever lose money and I'm up at
least 30% so that's e rward another good
example is my friend Richard Branson and
if you know Sir Richard now as they call
it and Richard's a fun guy he's like um
look He he'll take risk with his life
he'll like get in a balloon go go on a
spaceship he's like the oldest 21y old
in the world that guy that guy's just
having fun all the time except not when
it comes to investing when it comes to
investing he's like what's the downside
how do we protect against the downside
that's why he's so successful and so
when he was going to take on British
Airways with you know building his own
Airlines think of the expense and the
risk of buying bowling Jets 150 250 Jets
so he NE negotiated for a year with
Boeing till he finally got the degree
that he'd buy all these Jets but a year
from now if he was not able to be
profitable in business or stay in the
business he could return all the Jets
with no credit loss no cost to him
whatsoever so he had zero downside only
upside that's how these guys play and
then the fourth one is diversification
and when I went through those and saw
them with everybody what triggered this
latest book The reason I decided to
write this final book was I saw that
waitest second the most successful
people have a different asset allocation
they're getting much more asymmetrical
risk reward and I also my conversations
with Ray doio learned a principal I
asked Ry 12 13 years ago we first became
friends I said you know I I prepared for
like 11 hours for my interview with him
was supposed to be 30 minutes and with
three and a half hours because he got
into it with me he was great and we
became friends and I asked him one
question I asked him was okay out of all
things we've talked about is there one
principle above all others that would be
the most important investment principle
that would make somebody wealthy if they
practiced it he goes Tony I have
wrestled with that for more than a
decade and I can tell you what it is he
goes I call it the Holy Grail of
investing which is why that that's the
title of this book it's really Rey it's
not me right and I said well I've lean
for what is it he said Tony in order for
people to get what they want Financial
Freedom they've got a compound right
well in order to get higher rates of
return you got to take bigger risks
which then could cost you getting to the
goal that's why I I said location
finding that balance what's right for
you is so important he said but I
discovered something mathematically if
you can find 8 to 12 uncorrelated
Investments he said you can reduce your
risk by
80% and make a slight increase in your
upside he said you're eliminating 80% of
the risk he go Tony that is the most
important thing that's out there people
don't know this but now for your
audience I'm sure they understand in
case they don't if you think about
correlated versus non correlated stocks
and bonds would be an example right when
the econom is going great people want
the growth that comes in stocks when
thoughts going go great they expect that
bonds are going to get them through it
right they're not necessarily correlated
so I wrote down the principle I started
looking to try to find things that are
not correlated it's rough in the world
we're in today so much is tied together
in the public markets and so sure enough
as I started doing this looking around I
came across an interesting statistic
that blew my mind and here's what it is
in the last 35 years every stock market
in the world has produced a smaller
return than private Equity average
private equity in that same time so I'll
give you an example most people know the
S&P 500 the index of the top 500
companies in stock market and if you
invested in the S&P over the last 35
years you had an average of a 9.2%
compounded return which is amazing you
know you're at 5% you're doubling your
money every 14 and a half years if
you're you know at 9% it's every eight
years that's big jump but if you're an
average private Equity not the people I
interview this book people I interview
this book are the 13 biggest in the
world so they have like 20% or more
compounded for decades one of them in
this book is 37% compounded for 26
straight years I it's unbelievable right
so when you're compounding that it goes
crazy but the average is 14.2 per year
so understand this you're compounding
50% greater every single year compounded
so so what does that mean if you put a
million dollar in the S&P 535 years ago
and forgot about it it's worth $26
million today it's unbelievable but if
you put a million dollars in the average
not these guys in the average private
Equity of 14.2 you have $139 million in
the same money in the same amount of
time so I was like whoa now what are the
ultra high netw worth people have 40 4%
of of their Assets in private equity and
private real estate so I started digging
into that area and that's what this book
was all about yeah I really liked it
there a great chart we should throw up
it said what was the lowest fiveyear
returns by asset class lowest five years
so like how bad can the bad get because
everybody tells you about the good
nobody tells you about the bad usually
and I love this one because private
credit was the only one that had a
positive return in its lowest five years
in the last 30 years 20 years something
like that so it was it was cool to see
these different asset classes that most
people don't have the knowledge of or
the access to and I think that's the the
premise of the book so who are the
people what's the largest number of
billionaires and most people think it's
Tech and it's not and then they think
it's real estate and it's not it's
financial services but it's not hedge
funds and it's not BC funds some BC
funds but not most I very small it's
private Equity because they have the
money for five years so when the market
goes down they don't have to sell they
buy when the market goes up they sell
they have the room to play right to get
things done and they're not just trying
to buy something with the right timing
they're buying a company and making it
better bringing new marketing bring in a
new CEO bringing in new systems and
building up and then selling it private
or taking it public so they have a lot
more flexibility and they're the they're
the Masters of the Universe so I was
like okay let's see what they're doing
and my friend I said I'm getting into
some of these private Equity but the
very best are like you know going to a
club and you're you got plenty of money
and you're outside if you're not
good-look you don't know everybody
you're not getting in that club I don't
care how much money you have right it's
very similar like you know buying a
Ferrari and any Ferrari yes but the
newest hot sp3 you know they cost 4
million bucks you can't even buy it cuz
they're all gone already by collectors
who buy them before they even come out
well it's very similar for the best
people in private Equity I saying I've
gotten a few because of my name and some
relationships but the amount I'm getting
is too small and he just Tony goes um
I'll tell you a little secret I'll tell
you where I put the majority of my money
and this guy's very very wealthy very
successful so I'm leaning in and he goes
there's this firm in Houston Texas like
it's Houston Texas I he's going to say
Singapore London you know New York
Connecticut right he goes yeah they're
off the beaten path they're the best at
this
they have found a way they're the
biggest in the world right now one of
the three biggest and they said they
found a way where you don't have to buy
into the fund where you can buy into the
company and own a piece of the company
and you own all their funds now if you
know how these funds work they make 2%
on your money they tie it up for five
years and you're willing to tie it up
because of the greater returns right but
they make 2% of your money if they don't
make you anything every year so they
have a built-in income that's great and
then they get 20% of The Upside if they
make you a bunch of money they get 20% %
of that and it's not uncommon for them
to go from a billion to two billion in
five years so they make a 100 million
fees in those five years and they make
another 20% on a billion they make $300
million on a billion dollar investment
that's why they're the wealthiest people
in the world like I got know how to do
this so I met with these guys in Houston
I became a client and then I eventually
invested with them I'm partner with them
and then I was like man we got to get
this out but nobody could take advantage
of it now they can't so as a result we
put it out there so you can imagine I
own now 65 of the largest private Equity
firms I own a piece of them as a partner
in every fund that they have so and I'm
not there working every day till 2 in
the morning like they are in those
pieces the other one I'll tell you about
is you read the book so you know is
sports I always wanted to own a sports
team I was gr totally poor you wanted to
be a baseball player right that's right
you got a good memory I used to go to
Dodger Stadium every once in a r Moon
way off in the Deep far seats in right
field the cha s you could bue and I I
bled dodger blue I'm a piece of the
Dodgers but to get to that point the
first team I was able to make a purchase
of and be a partner in was the Lac
football club the soccer team there we
built the stadium I got to help design
it it was fun I got to with my friend
Peter goober is just a genius but the
amount of money time and energy and the
amount of like a microscope in your bum
that they do to qualify you is
mindboggling right to do it so but now
in all these sports teams I even have
competing teams because rule was changed
three years ago this is amazing only a
few firms have been able to do it and
the rule allows you to buy a small
sliver of teams and why would you want a
sports team because they're not
correlated to the stock market in
inflationary Times sports teams do well
they've done extremely well they rais
the price the hot dog people pay it
doesn't matter and they used to be just
putting butts in seats but that's not
true anymore so I'll give you an example
you know this if you read the book um my
partner Peter G bought the Dodgers with
a group of people Magic Johnson B group
people I'm part of it now too and when
they bought it they paid $2 billion doll
for the fur and everybody's freaking out
right I remember the news people are
like this is a crazy buy because no one
paid more than 800 million for a sports
team and most people believe the Dodgers
is worth a billion but not two billion
so I went to Peter I like I know you're
not dumb I know the smartest guy I know
so you must know something no one else
knows if we're going to do this tell me
goes Tony you know I like making movies
with Cliffhangers he said I want to make
you wait three days CU I'm making
announcement when you hear the announcer
come over L A little party together they
made the announcement he sold the local
TV rights just the local TV rights for 7
billion made five billion on the
spot so why because sports teams now are
media Enterprises of the 100 best shows
most watch shows last year 92 were
sporting events and they'll watch the
ads because everybody's cord cutting
everywhere else and going and watching
things you know streaming Sports the
only thing live you want to see in real
time for to have value for you and they
can do those ads so and they buy real
estate today they they are unbelievable
organizations so now I'm a part of the
Dodgers of the Warriors the Red Sox the
Pittsburgh Penguins I mean I go on and
on and on and I have the ownership
benefits but I also have something
that's not correlated so it's one by 8
to 12 plus on top of that you share in
the revenues of every other team's media
in other words it's equal share if
you're a small team or a big share you
keep your local media that you get to
sell locally so the income streams are
amazing I'll give you an example Michael
Jordan we actually bought it Michael
Jordan bought the Charlottes for 275
million controlling interests 12 and a
half years ago he just sold us we're one
of the buyers as a group of buyers for
three billion that's his return on that
time period in the last 10 years if you
take the NBA the the Major League
Baseball soccer and hockey those four
together they've averaged between them
18% compounded during that time versus
11% they in the S&P 500 so just you're
only doubling your return having fun
having something you're part of that's
really cool and people can have an
experience that they once dreamed about
without having billions of dollars and
go through all the hell of it so there's
so many opportunities like this and
people can get it get the book it's at
the the Holy Grail of investing.com I
think there's like a free chapter so you
can go download the fre chapter listen
there's a free audio chapter you can
listen to and then you can pre-order the
book it comes out in a few weeks I know
we're over but I got to ask you for one
thing sure the one thing is we talked a
lot about money making it and all that
stuff one of the things I pulled away
from you was about giving and I think
you know when you when I was at the
event you were talking about oh I've
given I give this many meals every year
I think now it's like a billion meals
some insane number of because you know
you remembered what it was like to not
have food and a part of me was like I'm
gonna do that someday I should do that I
should did myself again I should do that
the future when I you know when I'm rich
I'm GNA do that too and I think this is
probably a pretty common thing easy for
him he's Rich what does it mean what
does it matter to him to write a $5
million check right I wish it was just
five million
until well right fair enough until you
told a story about giving early on and
give and I I I just want you to tell
this one story because I think for most
people if they made it to this part this
will make a bigger difference in their
lives than anything else that you tell
them because I know it did for me you
told the story about going to the salad
bar oh yeah going to a salad bar you're
24 years old and you're broke and you
had a giving moment that sort of shifted
you would you please just tell that one
because I think giving is not something
you got to wait till you're rich to do
which is I think the common
misconception I tell people if you won't
give a dime out of a dollar you're not
going to give 10 million out of 100
million or you know 100 million out of a
billion don't kid yourself right and
also the value of giving transforms you
out of scarcity but the background on it
is I was working for Jim Ron this
personal development speaker and I
really did well and then I did poorly
for a while and I was really frustrated
I was working hard I wasn't getting the
return I was totally broke you know
you're in business you make some
mistakes and I found myself totally
broke again and I'm in this 400 foot
bachelor apartment in Venice California
feeling sorry for myself and watching
Luke and Laura on General
Hospital it was just terrible and um I'm
down to my final you know 1920 21 $22 I
wasn't some change I haven't paid my
rent and I got to figure out what to do
and what to eat so my focus was okay I'm
going to go to this all you can e salad
bar taco bar and I'm going to load up
for for the winter um and you know spend
five bucks in the you know and then I
didn't drive there because it was only
about three miles but I couldn't pay
three bucks for parking too it was just
I couldn't do that so anyway long story
short I get to the place it's on the
water in Marena Del ra it's why I went
there there's boats going by and I I
can't I don't have a pot to pee in right
but I'm visualizing and then my my I a
stack of food this high and then the I
could see the front door because where I
was sitting and the front door opens and
this beautiful woman walks in she was
just absolutely gorgeous I couldn't help
but look then I waited to see if there
was a guy with him as if I had any shot
at this right and she had a guy with him
unfortunately and he was about 3 feet
tall and he had a little vested suit on
little tie and you know he opens the
door for her and he pulled out the chair
for her and I was just I was
mesmerized and I was moved and I got
emotional I don't know why I don't know
if it's thinging my own Mom I don't know
what it was at the time but anyway the
bottom line is when I was done eating I
went baited it was 5.95 or something
like that and I had the rest of the
money in my pocket I had no plan for
this and I I'm walking out the door
there's that little boy with his mom and
her back's to me so I didn't talk to her
I wasn't going to her I just went up to
him because I was so moved and I just
said hey I said my name's Tony what's
your name I can't remember his name
anymore you know Johnny or whatever it
was and he goes uh I said Johnny I said
you are a Class Act I said I just want
you to know I have so much respect for I
saw you hold the door for your lady I
saw you pulled the chair out for her
you're so present with her and I said
take it her lunch like this he goes well
she's my mom and I said well that's even
more impressive he goes I can't take her
to lunch because you know I'm just 11
and and I saides you can I have no plan
for it just reached in my pocket took
all the money out in the world $19
whatever was left over and dumped it on
him with the change and everything right
in front of him and his eyes got big and
you know garbage can covers and he goes
I can't take that I said sure you can't
he said how come I said because I'm
bigger than you are and then I smiled
and he laughed and I didn't even look at
the woman I didn't do it for
acknowledgement I just walked out that
door to get my car and then realized I
didn't have my car there because I'd
walk so I I look like a stupid white guy
skipping my ass I'm sure all the way
home I mean I was high as a kite and I
had no money and I got home and I was
still cool about it and I was full GL I
so much and I woke up the next morning
with no plan no idea no nothing and no
money and it's like I mean no money not
a dollar and no one to call to get money
from and it was a guy had loaned a,
to about two and a half years before
when I really didn't have it but he
needed it more than I did I loaned it to
him so I've been for months been calling
and sting you know regular mail to him
because it wasn't answering the phone it
was no email those days and um and that
morning I get my mail and no no call no
response that when I get my mail there's
all the bills and there's a handwritten
note and I open the note and it's from
this guy apologizing to me and telling
me that he was so sorry I was there for
him when he really needed it and he had
not been there for me and he had put in
you know an extra $200 for interest and
so forth so was
$1,200 $1,200 is more money than I could
live on that for a month in those days
right and I just started crying
uncontrollably I was like you know why
am I crying this is beautiful this is
beautiful you know it's like and then I
realized wow you know when I had nothing
I gave everything and here this is what
does this mean I said I don't know what
it means but I'm going to decide it
means because I didn't give to get and I
didn't give what was easy that's why I'm
receiving and it's like that day on I
can tell you I've had ups and downs I
have so many companies the early days I
had a couple companies on the verge of
bankruptcy they didn't go bankrupt thank
God I hung on and made it through it but
I never felt that scarcity I never felt
that scarcity again since that day
because if you get to that point your
brain realizes there's more than enough
and you can give when you feel like
there's nothing there that's that's what
transforms you when I interviewed Sir
John temp
who's the first billionaire investor
started with
nothing he said to me that the secret to
wealth is gratitude right because
doesn't matter how much money you have
if you're not grateful you're not rich
um but then he said also I've never met
anybody that tithed for at least 10
years who didn't become wealthy he said
Ty there doesn't have to be a church
it's just taking 10% of what you're
earning and giving it away and I'm proud
to say I've given away 177% and I've
done quite well um but I did it when I
had nothing it's it's there um I want to
play one more seed with the audience
though and that is if they'd like to
have an experience you know they can't
come for the you know three or four days
yet for an event but they'd like to have
an experience since Co started four
years ago everybody was trapped at home
and I was doing stadiums you know and
they started shutting down the stadium
tell like put 100 people in the stadium
so I decided I'd build a studio and I'd
build these 20 foot high you know walls
67 resolution I could see everything and
I went to the guys you know who built
zoom and I said look you know I need you
to help me get to 20,000 30,000 people
not a thousand I built software so that
people could instead of clapping could
shake their phone it would send electric
signal and if one person did hear
nothing when 20,000 people do it it's
like thunder and it allowed me to
literally explode in the number of
people I reach so now I do a free
seminar once a year for three days it's
coming up January 25th through 27th just
in about a week and a half if you want
to go there's zero charge it's not
partially free it's totally free and
it's about two and a half hours three
hours a day of immersion for three days
in a row and it's really designed to
help you get a plan and make the change
is necessary in your energy and your
emotions in your business in your
finances in your career and we just we
put the most we can in those three days
and create huge momentum and last year
we had over a million people again from
195 countries in the world and then
you're part of a community of people
helping each other so if anyone like to
go you're welcome to you can do it from
your home or your office you can bring
friends or family again there's no
charge you just go to what is that what
is the Highlight it's the uh
it's the time toise summit.com time
toise summit.com it starts January 25th
through the 27th and I'd love to serve
you guys and go
deeper amazing Tony I don't know if you
know this but at that event when you
told some of these stories I on the
moment in that moment I was like you
know what uh I'm gonna start giving and
the the idea I came up with I go you
know this was a pretty crazy experience
I had I just got lucky I bought some
Black Friday tickets uh I don't know how
I stumbled into this but this was cool
and I've I'm a different guy right now
and I decided all right I'm GNA start
giving I what I did was I said all right
next year I'm going to send one person
to this I'm going to give somebody an
experience to go to upw and I was like
every year I'm gonna gift more people
than the year before so I've sent 44
people now to your events you know my
mom my dad I know anybody anybody who
you know other entrepreneurs who I
thought you know might like it yes and
uh how they responded to this result how
did they react out these events 15% of
people are um like me they're like they
come back and it's like did somebody
plug you in you're like electric now
what happened to you so 15% of people
they're a new person never looked back I
would say 70% of people were like that
was a great experience I loved it and
they're like you know but they didn't
fully get like you know for me it was
like a a full transformation just being
totally honest so 70% of people all the
Paul experience yeah exactly and then I
would say 50% of people were like what
the hell is this um you know this was I
don't know what this is and they often
you know a lot of people I send are like
successful tech people and they come in
almost like they want to be the smart
guy in the Reddit comments almost and
they're like you know they're so worried
about he said this and is that the real
sta it 54% or 51% I'm like you're
missing the point trying to be so you
know you're you're being so smart you're
being dumb right now and so people have
everybody has their own experience I
think it's uh you know what I tell them
is just go have the experience right go
go decide for yourself uh so you know
for people who listen to this I'm gonna
put a thing in the in the description I
want to send people who actually listen
to the podcast because I've been sending
people I know but now uh you know this
year I'll send I want to double it so I
think I've sent 44 people lifetime I to
to send another 44 people this year so
I'll put a thing in the comments for
people who go to the 4day upw that's
your kind of like starter event uh
that's the one I've been to a couple
times and uh I think you really like
since you're gonna do that I'll match it
so we'll make it away 80 in total you do
your 40 and I'll give you 40 uh to match
it since uh we'll we we'll we'll invest
in these people's lives together amazing
thanks so much Tony I really appreciate
it great talking with you and
congratulations on what you built yeah
likewise